hello everybody and welcome to candid
Truth where the truth is not optional
but the
standard um I know Mikey has his saying
of what he will say it is it is getting
candid with it but that's what I say um
and so I hope you guys are having a
wonderful Friday um leading into the
weekend thank you guys so much for being
here and tuning in so we've had a few
questions about the holidays
presentations and I'd like to go ahead
and address those so the question is how
or what do we do instead of the holidays
or what do we do with the
holidays and my answer to you would
be well it's time given to us by the
government
and I think we should take that time we
should use it to have family and friends
around and be a good witness to them to
do things together that are Godly share
a meal eat good food take care of your
health go on walks do activities that
are glorifying to God on them still just
do not do the traditional foods and
activities or rituals um so for me and
my family uh just a little
snapshot we are kind of a mixed family
um a little more than half of of my
family are
not what I would say are even Christian
and so even growing up as a young child
I had to figure out how to deal with all
of that along with the leading of my
parents um they didn't know how to deal
with it much either but they were great
parents and we all just had to kind of
Heap love upon these people um we still
get together with some who are willing
to kind of
um to do so others have gotten tired as
many will of hearing your beliefs and
may stop attending activities and family
get togethers with you that is something
you really cannot do uh I mean cannot
change for them if they decide to do so
and that's not the goal the goal is to
actually take this time together if they
are willing to do that and make them see
God's glory
like I said you can go on walks you can
go um let's just say that we have
Memorial Day right Memorial days
technically I'll be covering this uh
it's one of
the pagan holidays as well and you end
up going and you you book tickets we've
done this in my family you book tickets
to the botanical gardens for the entire
family it's fun it's a good way of
getting everyone to come together and
have time together you talk as you walk
through the gardens you have a wonderful
time and then you share a meal later
it's just all this stuff that you can do
together you can picnic just bring them
outside let's see the sunset let's spend
time together do a fire together you
don't have to do again the s'mores or
having a turkey dinner for Thanksgiving
or a ham for um Easter or painting eggs
or any of that uh I know it's hard these
days cuz some children and families are
really steeped in media and technology
and their phones and you all just take
time to unplug at least that's what we
do in my family we actually get the
puzzles out remember the pieces that are
cardboard that you put together um we do
puzzles we do watch some good movies
together um mostly they're Bible movies
and stories like
Paul's I guess we watched the last time
we watched was Paul's Redemption story
um from Saul to Paul and although my
family members were there that were not
quite Christian they handled it quite
well um there are other movies that
are better I'm sure to watch with non
believing family members that have a
Christian theme and have good morals um
I just don't always have them right off
the top of my head to get to give to you
guys and tell you about them but there
are many options there's I don't know
painting I've done that we actually do a
lot of what God gave us around us to
spend time with the animals rocking I
don't know if you guys like rocking
chairs or Porch Sitting um I'm bringing
that back I love that and you sit there
with the animals and each other and you
talk or enjoy the sunset
enjoy iced tea together make bake stuff
together actually that's one of the best
things we did last holiday that we had
we all got an ingredient out and we made
banana bread together or some kind of
bread like these are all things crafts
do crafts together and of course not to
celebrate or venerate that holiday
because I know some crafts are
associated with certain holidays but try
just
I don't know like
origami origami or painting or drawing
or I like to draw
mugs um and it literally I don't I'm not
a great artist I'm not a great drawer
but a Sharpie on a mug you can write
just names on it you can just have what
comes to you
but it's pretty amazing how much you can
connect with people like the real
connection that come out of these kinds
of interactions that I hope you guys
want and will be able to have based on
what I'm telling you with your family as
well
so that is all I can really tell you
guys um from my own experience it's gone
over well most people don't realize that
are people in the family that don't
really believe and they know the holiday
rituals they know the
traditions and they know something's
different but some of them will even
forget that you've left those out of
your holiday celebration they'll be like
wait a minute we didn't do this or we
didn't do that and um that's good to
hear it's actually that they have had
fun that day you got them lost in
talking and connecting and having a good
time without having to do any of those
things that is what you want that is
what God wants for all of us to even
bring others to the truth and to bondage
with
him kind of without pushing it in their
face or having to tell them to do so but
just enjoying by example his presence
because of you and how you decided to
run your day or your celebration day and
um it's not really a celebration day
it's just another day so I don't know if
that helps I hope it does um but this is
how I would advise you to deal with the
holiday holiday I hope you've been
blessed by this and that it's very
helpful um if you guys would like some
specific advice um I'm not sure like for
instance actually this comes to mind
I've been invited by other family
members and I've had this question
before what if you were invited to go to
other people's houses other family
members who you know will have a
Christmas tree have presents uh Easter
they'll have the painting of the eggs
they'll have cookie I guess painting
eggs that are cookies or frosting I'm
sorry frosting cookie
eggs
um and they will all have certain things
you know that you are like Halloween
they're going to dress up and such you
can go I have gone and you don't do the
dressing up you don't do the painting of
eggs you literally again are there as
though you were one of the Apostles and
Jesus sitting in their living room you
are you and you have a nice attitude and
you invest in them you care about them
you ask them how they are
doing and be interested in their latest
activities their work all these things
and while you are there usually I will
be honest usually you can try to
separate your time that you have to be
there into a very planned hour to two
hours maybe it's even less than that
maybe you have have a pretty crazy or
traumatic family um environment that's
okay so I do that actually planned like
we'll be there for an hour it's fine and
you do your family and you sit there and
you do this and if they have all of a
sudden an opportunity presents itself
where you can bring up puzzles or games
or things that are
more glorifying to God or benign neutral
or even have morals you decide to put in
your vote for that basically if they go
hey we can watch this this this and this
go for the best one and then you can you
can all put your vote in they sometimes
they don't choose what you wanted but
that's another situation sometimes where
you decide to be with the group that's
around the table um talking around the
food while the movie is going on you can
always pull yourself out of that
environment literally if you have to
leave with your family like if they're
watching a terrible movie and your your
kids and yourself are going to be quite
um traumatized by
it and that's okay sometimes you need to
do that you don't need to make a big
scene sometimes but you just I think we
need to go now um just be very polite
and you really just want them to have a
good time with you and see that you can
be normal you can be happy but you are
about higher things in life you are
elevating others and you're trying to be
loving and it speaks volumes it's the
higher calling that Jesus would talk
about um making people feel seen heard
and
loved despite the fact that they do
things and say things and live
differently than you would want them
to and um that is how yeah like I don't
know how else to advise you but that is
what I've had to do in my family
and it's amazing how many weeks to
months to years later they will say
something like
hey you are a Christian
right why do you believe that what is
your stance on this or why didn't you
decorate those eggs on that Easter when
you came is it because I mean it depends
they can be quite blunt just is it
because you guys are kind of weird
like and that's okay let them describe
and say things the way they're going to
you can't control their people's
language their behavior but you can
control you and your way of
being and so let's all reflect Jesus and
his I like to say like I said the
apostles like if you were in their
inside ring of of being present there
with these people and in these
environments what you would do what kind
of environment you would create you are
as um David ashri says you are
not the thermostat that just reads a
temperature you are the thermometer
itself you need to set the temperature I
think I have that right I might not but
you know what I I mean that you need to
set the temperature of what is going on
not just reflect what is going on
so again um I hope that all helps and
enjoy I know it sounds funny but enjoy
the holidays with your family then just
make it again a Godly thing so that is
the full discussion on that um there
will be other parts to the holiday
series of course there will be a part
two and a part three um for the other
two quarters of the year the first one
came out already if you're you're tuning
in for the first time please go watch
that and thank you for others that are
here joining um I hope that you guys
have also seen part one of the holiday
Deep dive and that you actually have
seen some other preliminary videos such
as who is the
Rainman and um the other videos on
androgyny and and such will give you
foundational understandings of where
some of these pagan holidays also
contribute and originate so that you can
have that knowledge of whether or not as
a Christian we should really be
participating and keeping the holidays
so we have also um shirts on our
website that you can go ahead and
purchase to support us we would love
that and we appreciate all the support
that has been given to us thus far we
couldn't do it without you guys and we
also have our donation page that has all
of our links
please um go ahead and support us there
if you can if you want to thank you so
much we love you guys and I'll be
signing off now happy Friday